a lot of people call this training gee
i don't call it she was
because
it means that the uh that uk gets to do
whatever they want as well
you do whatever you want but they do
whatever they want that's g was i call
this play
okay
as it reminds me when little kids like
play grown up even like you read to a
baby and baby can't speak yet but they
notice that you're looking at the book
and they start making noises so that
they'll start googling as as you're
reading the book and they're looking at
the pages they do the whole thing right
or sometimes they they've seen you
talking to people
and when you start talking to them they
just play that game oh this is where we
we make sounds with our mouth and and
look at each other okay and they're not
speaking they're not they don't
understand the words they don't have the
language language yet but whatever
element they can get out of it
they put into it okay
so
uh
the rules of play is it's somewhere
between kihon waza and g wasn't so g was
as anything goes well that's not it and
then kihon was says everything is
prescribed do you see
but in play
um
the nagy gets to do whatever technique
they want to do with within the set
parameters that you're working on okay
so here we're doing we're working on
mount reversals and just some of the
basic attacks from there okay
um
and then the uk is still pretty
controlled do you see so they're just
staying in their administrative starting
position and letting you do the
techniques do you see um it's it's a
step towards gus do you understand okay
but only if i play right
okay
if you start doing some weird stuff
right uh then we're not going to use it
as a stepping stone okay so for example
in g was i can't take pauses
i can't pause any pause that i make as
the naga is an escape they're out
they're gone okay
um
since i'm playing i get to decide the
pace
so you can go as slow as you want but
the tempo must remain
constant we can't have a pause in there
do you get it
and then you want to obey all of the
principles of not only the basics you're
working on but the larger principles and
the strategy
of the art so no space remain heavy
right and non-contestation be relaxed
okay uh do you understand it doesn't do
any good that you're in here and you're
doing the basics incorrectly or you're
violating principles or strategy or that
you're not relaxed okay or that you have
these pauses in there all right so
um
it's i'm just very relaxed
you see and i'm going to do the
maneuvers
that i've been practicing
right in a way
that uh
i can do something with it do you see
so i got up and checked his arm and
here's where i can have my uh
[Music]
one of the principles of my locks under
control conditions
is if i have to use a lot of strength or
a lot of movement that lock is not going
to work under live conditions so you
should
test yourself
with that kind of stuff okay
um
let's see
it doesn't make sense to come here start
punching him in the face and there's
that hand right there
and then again not big movements
tiny movements we'll do it
one steady pace without pauses
tight heavy relaxed smooth okay
try it again
okay so play in tachiwaza is gonna
follow the same rules okay so there's no
po no pausing you cannot pause and you
cannot give those openings so he uke
cannot stop moving but
not just moving around the map
traversing it means their kazushi
pattern must be constant okay do you get
that and uh
you cannot end play with a uh kihon
uh koku roku pin because that's not an
actual pin so you either have to
actually have a pin
uh maybe go into your network
or get some of your other
multi-limb controls or you go with some
sort of break or dislocation that they
tap out of or you're doing a projection
okay and projection means
away from me
not under me okay if you threw someone
and they landed under you you have to do
one of those other two
or stomps or kicks or something like
that or you have to move yourself away
projection means they're away and then
the play would simulate um that's where
you would draw your weapon or make your
escape okay
um
but then also you're trying to harmonize
yin
so anything that you have to use a
muscle here just that's not going to
work just like him that was okay
and then uh
let's just try
okay so he keeps moving and he's always
going to sleep
okay
so
so i keep moving he keeps moving
i don't have to go fast
i don't have to go hard okay
got it all right do you see how it just
keeps moving flowing flowing all right
let's try i know his throat looks a
little violent and stuff but sometimes
some people watch the video and go oh
that knock is so soft like it's a soft
technique of course they're not that we
get right
um but you want to train at that level
especially in play okay so i don't want
to do this technique like this
that that's not sumiya touch
okay
do you see that was a young young clash
so i'm doing all these techniques up
here
all these are here
oh
i could of course
so
shhh
let's see the difference in our energy
though
do you see
okay
part of your art is that you don't do
big man iq big man aikido is not aikido
okay it's not even jiu jitsu
you have to harmonize yin and yang
and play
is
a level of training
where the start
and the ending
are a little bit more free than kihon
wasa do you see so you have to learn
these adaptability skills
and not
stop doing the art because that's not
adaptation
you're just bustling now
okay